und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und christian sievers
guten abend inhalten das wetter passt
nicht zur weltlage der frühling ist da
die nachrichten bleiben winterlich
düster es ist zum verzweifeln vielleicht
ist das gerade ihre reaktion
verständlich aber auch in der
derzeitigen lage gilt die hoffnung
aufgeben bedeutet nach der gegenwart
auch die zukunft preiszugeben das ist
mehr als ein satz es gibt gerade jetzt
denkerinnen und forscher analysten und
strategen deren prognosen klingen nicht
nach verzweiflung sondern nach einer
chance für diese welt sie alle blenden
dabei nicht aus was auch heute wieder
geschieht in der ukraine etwa 300
luftangriffe sollen es allein in den
letzten 24 stunden gewesen sein schätzt
das us verteidigungsministerium auch
kiew haben die angriffe getroffen wieder
die schlimmsten angriffe heute in der
region um aktiv im nordosten des landes
und beim iq live im süden die sinnlose
zerstörung das missachten grundlegender
menschenrechte der schrecken dieses
krieges all das zeigt auch die andere
seite umso klarer auf was wir aufpassen
müssen wie viel uns unser leben wert ist
und was wir jetzt dafür tun sollten drei
thesen am anfang dieser sendung
zusammengefasst von christian kirsch und
kamran zafira
tag 27 des russisch-ukrainischen krieges
der eigentlich ein krieg ist zwischen
militaristischer despotie und
freiheitlichen werten noch immer wirkt
der westen schockiert warum eigentlich
offenbar gehen lebenslügen der
freiheitlichen gesellschaften in flammen
auf hat das auf längere sicht auch sein
gutes drei thesen unseren freiheitlichen
gesellschaften wohnt immer auch der hang
zur selbstkritik in das ist okay und
ausdruck freier debatte nur fühlen wir
uns dadurch vielleicht schwächer als wir
sind tatsächlich ist deutschland auch
jetzt wieder zuflucht und hoffnung sword
für millionen eine last aber auch
ausdruck immenser wertschätzung wir
sollten selbstbewusster sein denn unser
system ist viel besser als wir glauben
es ist schlicht überlegen das zu lernen
ist gut wenn demokratien nicht von außen
bedroht werden biken sie dazu
gewisse kleine unterschiede die sie
untereinander haben hoch zu spielen und
sich mit denen zu beschäftigen die
herausforderung von außen lässt das in
den hintergrund treten bp im augenblick
beobachten können die
zentrifugalkräfte die in der
europäischen union die ganze zeit
gewirkt haben spielen dem augenblick gar
keine rolle mehr jetzt geht es darum
sich gegen die große herausforderung von
außen zu verteidigen
zweitens geht die these krieg gehöre der
vergangenheit an zumal in europa
endgültig in rauch auf die folge
stärkung des weiterhin gering
geschätzten militärs jetzt wird klar
freiheit muss wehrhaft sein die
demokratien werden so stärker mutiger
unabhängiger freier auch in ihrer
außenpolitik auch das ist gut ich glaube
dass es vielleicht das einzig positive
ist was wir an dieser schlimmen
situation überhaupt haben dass wir uns
bewusst werden
was wir an unserer demokratie haben und
das ist auch ein ruck durch europa geht
anhand das beispiel ist der ukraine dass
wir diese demokratie auch verteidigen
müssen und dass begriffe wie
wehrhaftigkeit jetzt nicht mehr abgetan
werden als eine sprache
von ewiggestrigen nein wir wenn wir
diese demokratie setzen und wir schätzen
sie glaube ich also allermeisten müssen
wir sie auch verteidigen das heißt im
äußersten notfall eben auch
militärisch zu verteidigen schließlich
die behauptung durch handel ließe sich
gesellschaftlicher wandel erreichen war
eben immer nur eine behauptung davon
kann sich der westen verabschieden und
sich ehrlich machen und dabei lernen wir
sind nicht hoffnungslos in den
welthandel verstrickt wir können nein
sagen zum geschäft mit verbrechern und
trotzdem leben das ist auch gut die
erfahrung die wir jetzt gemacht haben
ist das wirtschaftliche macht zwar wirkt
aber nach einem anderen zeitkorridor
militärische macht wird schneller und
von daher ist dieses konzept wir
schaffen vertrauen als grundlage von
kooperationen so nicht aufgegangen und
es gibt einen zwang
auf uns lasten wie der mehr in
militärische fähigkeit militärische
macht zu investieren ergebnis könnte
also sein ein viel stärkerer bund
freiheitlicher demokratien die
selbstbewusste auftreten sich ihrer
ökonomischen und moralischen macht
wirklich bewusst werden und dazu
militärisch umfassend wehrhaft sind so
verteidigt sich die freiheit
verdanken werden wir das letztlich einen
moralischen führer im kreml ein
altes sprichwort aus spanien sagt
verzweiflung ist die lehrmeisterin des
unmöglichen
ich liebe dich mein teuerster mensch auf
dieser welt und ich höre nicht auf stolz
auf dich zu sein das hat julian avaya
ihrem mann heute geschrieben er kann
auch stolz sein auf sie und wenn wir
durchgehend druck standhalten müssen
schreibt sie noch dann werden wir auch
diese aufgabe meistern die aufgabe wird
alles andere als leicht alexej nawalny
sitzt seit gut einem jahr in einer
strafkolonie 100 kilometer östlich von
moskau
der kreml-kritiker soll so schnell nicht
freikommen heute hat ihn ein gericht zu
weiteren neun jahren straflager
verurteilt unter besonders harten
haftbedingungen aus moskau berichtet
christian sen
guten morgen zusammen begrüßt
keramischen der wein ist sprecherin die
zuschauer im livestream auf youtube eine
eigene sendung des nav allen die teams
zur urteilsverkündung über fünf stunden
programm mit anwälten experten eigenen
recherchen und analysen die freien
medien in russland sind kaltgestellt
navalny steam macht sein info programm
einfach selbst produziert außerhalb von
russland über das schicksal ihres chefs
zu berichten
es ist keine überraschung dass putin
alexej gerne so lange im gefängnis
sitzen lassen will wir an der macht ist
wir sind uns absolut sicher dass das
sein direkter befehl ist alexej zu
inhaftieren
im straflager in dem navalny schon seit
knapp einem jahr sitzt lässt putin zweck
gesperrter gegner die urteilsverkündung
in diesem viel kritisierten prozess über
sich ergehen wegen angeblicher
veruntreuung von geldern und wegen
beleidigung einer richterin neun weitere
jahre haft unter strengen bedingungen
seine anwälte befürchten dass sie dann
gar keinen zugang mehr zu ihm haben
wir müssen begreifen dass wenn putin an
der macht bleibt leicht eine weitere
anklage erhoben werden kann die zu einer
weiteren haftstrafe führen würden und
die größte sorge ist dass navis leben in
gefahr ist
[Musik]
rückblick im august 2020 überlebt
navalny in sibirien nur knapp einen
schock vergiftung in deutschland erholt
sich der 45 jährige von dem anschlag und
fliegt im januar 20 21 nach russland
zurück noch am flughafen in moskau wird
er festgenommen und später verurteilt
neben navalny werden fast alle kreml
gegner aus dem weg geräumt und die dazu
gezählt werden auch der politologe
karl-rudolf hat russland mittlerweile
verlassen wer kann in diesen tagen geht
politische einschätzungen in russland zu
machen ist heute eine ziemlich
gefährliche angelegenheit
ich glaube es ist besser die arbeit die
ich in russland geleistet habe woanders
fortzusetzen und das frei zu tun als
innerhalb russlands schweigen zu müssen
eine gefährliche zeit für
regierungsgegner journalisten für alle
die putin als feinde sieht nach dem
urteil heute wurden auch der wein ist
verteidiger vor dem straflager für kurze
zeit festgenommen und auch russland
schweden und keramisch aus navalny steam
stehen auf der russischen fahndungsliste
und
jetzt müssen wir über geld reden über
sehr viel geld geld das der staat
ausgeben will sich leihen muss dass wir
und unsere kinder irgendwann
zurückzahlen müssen
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
hat seinen ersten haushaltsentwurf im
parlament präsentiert im grunde sind es
gleich zwei pakete plus ein großes
fragezeichen noch mit dazu klar ist
damit schon mal eins die finanzpläne
über die der bundestag heute debattiert
hat werden schon bald veraltet sein
frank buchwald
so hatte er sich das wohl nicht
vorgestellt der erste haushalt des neuen
finanzministers erfüllt zwar manchen
wunsch klimapaket entlastungen moderate
neuverschuldung linden das planung aber
steht und einem kaum berechenbaren
vorbehalt die friedensdividende ist
verbraucht und deshalb hat der
bundeskanzler recht wenn er von einer
zeitenwende spricht auf die auch
deutschland reagieren muss wir werden
uns daher unseren wirtschaftlichen und
politischen gewicht entsprechend neu
aufstellen der etat hat ein volumen von
400 57,6 milliarden euro 99,7 davon sind
neue schulden hinzu kommen noch mal 100
milliarden für die bundeswehr ein
sondervermögen finanziert auf kredit
außerhalb der schuldenbremse abgesichert
im grundgesetz dafür aber braucht die
stimmen der union und die stellt
bedingungen die andere in der koalition
gar nicht gerne hören
ich rate ihnen der zug in ihrer ampel
dafür zu sorgen dass die ganzen
ausgabenwünsche nicht über diese 100
milliarden finanziert werden sollte egal
ob feministische außenpolitik oder
andere ideen sie haben dieses geld steht
für verteidigung und bündnisverteidigung
zur verfügung und für die bundeswehr
völlig anderes schärfer noch die anderen
oppositionsparteien die afg wirft der
regierung etikettenschwindel vor
die linkspartei spricht gar von
wettrüsten der finanzministerin
verteidigt stasi nicht die ökonomisch
unsinnige schuldenbremse aber für das
wettrüsten soll die schuldenbremse nicht
gelten da wird der turbo eingeschaltet
und das ist fatal tatsächlich will
lindner 2023 die schuldenbremse wieder
einhalten bisher kann jedoch keiner
abschätzen wie weit der krieg in der
ukraine den bund in die roten zahlen
treibt der minister kündigt deshalb ein
ergänzungs haushalt an weitere schulden
in unbekannter höhe jedoch am ergänzungs
haushalt werden nur maßnahmen ergänzt
die in einem unmittelbaren
zusammenhang mit den folgen des ukraine
krieges stehen was genau damit gemeint
ist bleibt offen für die grünen aber
gehört zu einer neuen sicherheitspolitik
auch eine schnellere energiewende
was jahrelang versäumt wurde wehrte
kollegen von der union ich sage nur cnh
regelung für windkraftanlagen los fiel
zwei verkauf der gasspeicher also was
jahrelang verdammt versäumt wurde das
kann selbst ein grüner
wirtschaftsminister nicht in wochen
ungeschehen machen so entscheidet der
bundestag über ein zahlenwerk das schon
heute mit vielen unbekannten rechnen
muss wie viel sie aber am ende ausmachen
weiß heute noch niemand
und dabei geht es ja um summen die man
sich nicht wirklich vorstellen kann da
gibt es den sehr menschlichen reflex
dann halt weniger exakt hinzugucken
dabei ist das natürlich genau falsch das
gegenteil ist richtig und wichtig gerade
bei diesen summen theo guten namen ein
haushalt mit großen und potenziell sehr
teuren fragezeichen drin was ist denn
ungefähr die größenordnung mit der der
finanzminister dann noch extra planen
muss
nun in der ampel koalition sprechen sie
von mindestens 25 milliarden euro die
union geht er von 50 milliarden aus das
hängt natürlich vom weiteren flüchtlings
aufkommen und von den weiteren kriegs
lasten ab aber nicht zu vergessen wir
reden da nur vom nachkommenden
nachtragshaushalt im heute vorgelegten
normalen haushaltsentwurf stehen ja
schon jetzt 100 milliarden schulden plus
100 milliarden sogenanntes
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr wobei
das wort vermögen ja eher aus der
politischen trick kiste stammt und in
der bewussten bedeutungs prägung ja eher
ein wort schöpfung wie das gute kita
gesetz erinnerten wir reden ja nicht von
vermögen sollen sie sind zusätzliche
schulden das mag in der jetzigen
krisensituation ja alles unvermeidlich
sein und eine von finanzminister lindner
nicht verschuldete last aber damit
steuert das land in die absolute
rekordverschuldung es gibt jetzt neben
einem sogenannten kernhaushalt inklusive
nachtragshaushalt auch noch große
schattenhaushalte und wie die
zurückzuzahlen sind das liegt auch noch
im schatten und dann theo kommt einiges
zusammen wenn man auf das ganz große
bild koark das wachstum ist in gefahr
die inflation steigt
ideen wie den bürgerinnen und bürgern
geholfen werden kann gibt es viele aber
tatsächlich umgesetzt sind die nicht ja
jedenfalls noch nicht es soll sich ja
bei der nächsten tagen ändern die
zuständige arbeitsgruppe aus neuen ampel
vertretern hat sich offensichtlich auf
ein zweites energiekosten entlastungs
paket geeinigt jetzt müssen noch die
koalitionsspitzen zu stimmen der spd
vorsitzender hat jedenfalls heute abend
noch für diese woche eine politische
verständigung angekündigten gespräch
sind ja bisher unter anderem ein tank
rabatt ein allgemeines oder nach
einkommen gestaffeltes mobilitäts geld
beziehungsweise eine einmalzahlung für
bedürftige finanzminister lindner hat
heute im bundestag eine kombination
verschiedener instrumente angekündigt
darin dürfte sich dann auch der zoff
spiegeln den es ja in der koalition über
die jeweiligen vorschläge gegeben hat
insbesondere über windows tank rabatt
war bei den beiden anderen parteien
heftig gestritten worden also über
details wird noch geschwiegen aber
weitere entlastungen bei den
energiekosten die scheinen jetzt sicher
und auch die werden natürlich wieder
kosten theo herzlichen dank für heute
abend auch in großbritannien debattieren
sie den haushalt und sie debattieren
über hilfen für die ärmsten deren zahl
in wirklich erschreckender weise steigt
für die briten kommt gerade alles auf
einmal die folgen von krieg
explodierenden energiepreisen cupid und
praxis zu viel für immer mehr menschen
wie diana zimmermann zeigt
die schlangen werden immer länger bei
manchester gibt die initiative das brot
und butter denkt drei tüten lebensmittel
für umgerechnet neun euro ab im
supermarkt würde das den arbeitslosen
ingenieure leicht 45 euro kosten
wir haben es wirklich schwer momentan in
den tüten ist alles was wir für eine
woche zum überleben brauchen
reallöhne sinken momentan so stark wie
bisher nur in einer rezession ein sturm
kommt auf die briten zu
irgend was ist falsch gelaufen wenn auch
familien die arbeiten sich nicht
ernähren können die leute haben so etwas
noch nie erlebt sie wissen nicht was sie
tun sollen sie sind wirklich am kämpfen
exit und kuwait haben den briten
zugesetzt 25 euro extra pro woche haben
bedürftige in der korona zeit bekommen
jetzt nicht mehr april steigt nun auch
noch der beitrag zur sozialversicherung
bislang gelten 4,5 millionen briten als
energie arm geben mehr als zehn prozent
ihres haushaltseinkommens für strom gas
und benzin aus bis oktober wird diese
zahl auf 8,5 millionen anwachsen schon
im letzten winter sind laut statistikamt
8500 menschen an den folgen kalter
wohnungen gestorben
energiepreise sind schon im vergangenen
jahr massiv gestiegen auch importe
würden immer teurer nach der russischen
invasion steigen die energiepreise jetzt
natürlich noch schneller und die
lebensmittelpreise galoppieren davon
wenn wir bisher dachten dass die
inflation sechs bis sieben prozent
betragen könnte mit sie nun mindestens
acht erreichen manche glaubten sogar
mehr als 10
morgen wird die regierung ihren haushalt
vorlegen der druck auf den
finanzminister einer beispiellosen krise
unter den ärmsten der gesellschaft
entgegenzuwirken ist groß regisseur jack
wird wohl die benzinsteuer senken nicht
aber auf höhere sozialbeiträge
verzichten mehr konnte der premier ihm
nicht abbringen wie zum trost erklärte
der seine landsleute kurzerhand zu
freiheitskämpfern
ich weiß dass es der instinkt der
menschen in diesem land wie in der
ukraine ist immer die freiheit zu wählen
ich kann ihnen einige bekannte beispiele
aus der jüngeren vergangenheit nennen
als die briten sich in großen zahlen für
den dragset entschieden hatte dass nicht
im entferntesten mit
ausländerfeindlichkeit zu tun sie
wollten nur frei sein
ein vergleich der selbst unter johnsons
parteifreunden für empörung sorgte und
tief blicken lässt wenn das brot knapp
wird und der strom teuer greift der
premier zu kriegsrhetorik
heute-journal update fragt man guckte
mir den ehemaligen wirtschaftsweisen
lars feld wer all die neuen schulden bei
uns hier in deutschland bezahlen soll
das nachher erst jetzt hier heinz mit
dem thema corona denn auch das ist nicht
weg im gegenteil ja die hohen corona
infektionszahlen in deutschland führen
auch zu belastungen und engpässen in
krankenhäusern der vorstandsvorsitzende
der deutschen krankenhausgesellschaft
gast sagte es geht wir flächendeckend
personalausfälle über alle stationen
hinweg und das treffen zusammen mit
soviel corona infektions patienten auf
den normal stationen wie man noch nie
gehabt habe etwa 24.000 seines derzeit
bundesweit
die aktuellen corona zahlen des robert
koch- institut meldet
222.000 80 neuinfektionen binnen eines
tages das sind 23.000 192 mehr als vor
einer woche
264 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incidents steigt auf 1.700 33,4 die
sieben tage incidents der
hospitalisierungen also der einweisungen
in die krankenhäuser ist weiter gesunken
auf
7,08
auch bundespräsident frank walter
steinmeier und seine frau elke
büdenbender haben sich mit dem corona
virus infiziert die symptome seien mild
teilte eine sprecherin in berlin mit der
bundespräsident und seine frau hätten
sich umgehend in häusliche isolation
begeben
in der südisraelischen stadt beerschewa
hat ein angreifer vier menschen getötet
und zwei weitere schwer verletzt der
mann sei von bewaffneten passanten
getötet worden teilte die polizei mit
der täter habe zunächst mit seinem auto
einen radfahrer gerammt und dann im
stadtzentrum auf fünf menschen
eingestochen
der israelische polizeichef sprach von
einem den sicherheitsdiensten bekannten
terroristen der bereits eine
gefängnisstrafe verbüßt habe details zur
identität nannte er nicht
bei einer bundesweiten razzia hat die
polizei in 13 bundesländern häuser und
wohnungen von über 100 verdächtigen
durchsucht ermittelt wird gegen online
hetzer die gezielt fake news und
beleidigungen in sozialen medien und um
die bundestagswahl 2021 verbreitet
hatten für viele politikerinnen und
politiker gehören hass und hetze im netz
mittlerweile zum alltag laut bka sind
zwei drittel der opfer frauen
es begann mit einem tweet und es ist
jetzt das wichtigste industrieprojekt im
osten deutschlands zwei jahre und vier
monate liegen zwischen dem tweet und der
eröffnung für ein industrieprojekt in
diesem land ist das geradezu
atemberaubend schnell das hat zu tun mit
der hoffnung die dieses land in die
zukunftstechnologie e autos setzt es hat
zu tun mit der aussicht auf
arbeitsplätze und mit der speziellen art
wie ein unternehmen und sein gründer
eigene ideen durchsetzen
ab heute kommen tesla autos auch aus
grünheide bei berlin nicola albrecht
zu hartem amerikanischen rap inszeniert
tesla-chef mast sich selbst und die
übergabe der autocheck karten
stadtschlüssel an die ersten 30 besitzer
der tesla modelle made in brandenburg
seine ansprache kurz die botschaft meine
fabrik wird zu einer besseren grüneren
zukunft beitragen also glaubt an die
zukunft
doch die leicht bizarre
werbeveranstaltung bekam angesichts des
zeitpunktes und der gäste schnell
ernsthaften staatstragenden charakter
bundeskanzler olaf scholz und
bundeswirtschaftsminister habeck sind
gekommen nach teslas rekordbauzeit von
nur zwei jahren ab heute
serienproduktion mit signalwirkung so
scholz es ist ein zeichen dass wir auf
den fortschritt setzen müssen die dinge
die wir heute schon können werden uns
keinen wohlstand schaffen in 10 20 oder
50 jahren sondern nur dinge die wir
jetzt neu anfangen und genau das ist das
was hier geschieht die stimmen von tesla
kritikern verhallen an diesem tag weit
entfernt vom event blockierten einige
wenige demonstranten die autobahn was
kritik angeht scheint der amerikanische
unternehmer ohnehin dünnhäutig das zdf
heute ausgesperrt worden mass karte sich
an kritischen beiträgen des senders
während der bauphase gestoßen und so
müssen wir den wirtschaftsminister
außerhalb des geländes zum interview
treffen es sei der ukraine kriegt er
zeige wie wichtig der umschwung zu
elektroautos gerade jetzt sei betont er
wir wollen unabhängig von russischen
werden das ist nicht trivial für
deutschland nicht trivial sie kennen die
debatte und zu zeigen wir können nicht
nur öl durch öl ersetzen sondern wir
können auch elektrisch ist natürlich
einen an diesem tag
ein schönes symbol mehr als ein symbol
es tesla für das land brandenburg
denn hier ist seit baubeginn viel in
bewegung geraten 3000 arbeiter
beschäftigt tesla aktuell 12.000 sollen
es werden sobald hier eine halbe
millionen autos jährlich vom band rollen
zulieferer haben bereits verträge
geschlossen doch vielleicht noch
wichtiger die sogwirkung setzt gerade
vor rund vier wochen hat genau hier im
brandenburgischen guben ein deutsch
kanadisches unternehmen das lithium wie
druck sieht für die batterien von
elektroautos produziert einen bauantrag
gestellt
wir haben dort andere große unternehmen
die ansässig sind wir jetzt eine tesla
in der produktion der autos wie eine
basf in der produktion der kathoden die
viele batterien benötigt werden und das
ist natürlich alles für uns potentielle
kunden und wir kriegen auch eine massive
unterstützung von der landesregierung
diese ganzen punkte zusammen genommen
sind sogar europaweit sehr einmalig es
ist die infrastruktur rund um tesla und
an vielen weiteren orten die noch
hinterherhinkt eine mammut aufgabe für
schwerfällige behörden brandenburgs
ministerpräsident verspricht tempo zu
machen der produktionsstart bei tesla
gibt ihm rückenwind zumindest für den
moment
tesla-chef milliardär elon musk twittert
heute nur zwei worte danke deutschland
wir bleiben noch bei der wirtschaft hat
für die rund 21 millionen rentnerinnen
und rentner in deutschland stets zum
ersten juli die erhöhung ihrer bezüge an
und wie heute bekannt wurde soll es die
höchste seit jahrzehnten werden von
bethmann wie kommt es gerade jetzt zu
dieser anhebung der hauptverantwortlich
ist immer die lohnentwicklung und nach
den corona bedingten einbrüchen der
gehälter sind die verdienste 20 21
wieder gestiegen so deutlich dass unter
berücksichtigung aller berechnungs
faktoren und das sind bei der
gesetzlichen rente einige die erhöhung
sogar kräftiger ausfällt als erwartet
demnach legen die renten ab dem ersten
juli und westdeutschland um 5,35 und in
ostdeutschland wegen der gesetzlichen
anpassungen an das westniveau noch
stärker um 6,12 prozent zu die für
dieses jahr zu erwartende inflation von
fünf bis sechs prozent relativiert die
hohen zuwächse allerdings unterm strich
also werden es die höheren altersbezüge
gerade mal schaffen den kaufkraftverlust
auszugleichen neue realitäten an die man
sich erst mal gewöhnen muss und noch
etwas fällt auf die ampel regierung
verschiebt ganz offenbar eines ihrer
wichtigen vorhaben die pläne zur
einführung einer aktien- renten- nämlich
die idee dass künftig einen teil der
rente am aktienmarkt erwirtschaftet
werden soll findet sich im aktuellen
bundeshaushalt nicht mehr wieder der
krieg in der ukraine setzt vorerst
andere prioritäten der dax kann heute
dennoch luft holen das kursbarometer
legt um gut ein prozent zu und das trotz
aller sorgen wie es in den kommenden
wochen und monaten weitergeht frank
bethmann vielen dank an mehreren
deutschen flughäfen sind durch
warnstreiks der privaten
sicherheitskräfte hunderte flüge
ausgefallen die gewerkschaft verdi hatte
nach der vierten gescheiterten
verhandlungsrunde zum ganztägigen
warnstreik aufgerufen
betroffen waren insgesamt neun flughäfen
darunter auch die drehkreuze frankfurt
am main berlin und hamburg verdi fordert
unter anderem ein lohnplus von
mindestens einem euro die stunde am
donnerstag sollen die tarifgespräche in
die nächste runde gehen
mehr als 700 flüchtlinge auf gerade mal
etwas über 100 einwohner das dörfchen
summte in niedersachsen wurde
international zum symbol für deutsche
flüchtlingspolitik das war 2015 damals
gab es auch in summte große sorgen große
befürchtungen schaffen wir das am ende
als alles vorbei war hatten sie das
geschafft aber es wurde dann auch wieder
einsam in sumter
winterschlaf jetzt wollen die summe neu
zeigen was sie können und was sie
gelernt haben seit heute sind die ersten
flüchtlinge aus der ukraine da aus
summte rollen
ein letzter check ob alles stimmt in nur
einer woche haben sie hier in sumter ein
bürokomplex umgebaut in einer
flüchtlingsunterkunft
gleich kommt ein bus mit den ersten
ukrainischen flüchtlingen an die welle
der hilfsbereitschaft ist groß in diesem
kleinen 100 einwohner dorf bei lüneburg
bisher sehr gut obwohl wir anfangs
fähigkeiten hatten wir hatten ja bis
letzten mittwoch kein wasser kein strom
kein licht und haben es wirklich
geschafft mit dieser großen freiwilligen
hilfe aus dem amt neuhaus und auch aus
dem landkreis lüneburg
dass wir das bis sonnabend schon die
ersten 200 zimmer spricht betten fertig
hatten schon bei der flüchtlingskrise
2015 nahm summte 750 menschen auf das
hat den ort berühmt gemacht journalisten
aus aller welt reisten damals in das
verschlafene nest sie recherchierten wie
dieses kleine dorf an der elbe mit so
vielen flüchtlingen klarkommt dabei
waren nicht alles unter 2015 glücklich
über die aufnahme von flüchtlingen in
ihrem winzigen dorf eine
informationsveranstaltung damals soll
die gemüter beruhigen die stimmung ist
aufgeheizt
wir haben ja bisher nur polizei von
montags bis freitags
es muss also ja auch irgendwo versichert
sein das machen wir selber backen
versorgung vor ort wir haben keine
einkaufsmöglichkeit wir haben wir haben
überhaupt nicht das chaos blieb aus die
gemeinde profitierte von den
flüchtlingen allein durch arbeitsplätze
im heim die vielen syrischen flüchtlinge
von damals sie sind nicht geblieben es
war eine notaufnahme die jetzt wieder
ihren betrieb aufnimmt was will man
anders machen bei den ukrainischen
flüchtlingen was hat man gelernt aus den
erfahrungen zum beispiel werden wir die
großen räume kleiner unterteilen
privatsphäre zu ermöglichen eine
erfahrung des letzten males große
schlafsäle sind der stimmung nicht
dienlich die ersten die da sind sie
freuen sich über die nächte in denen sie
endlich durchschlafen können
[Musik]
summte ein paar höfe zwei
bushaltestellen eine halbwegs große
kreuzung nach 800 metern ist alles
vorbei aber was wir haben sagen sie dort
jetzt ist ein guter ruf
das war unsere welt an diesem dienstag
und um 0.30 meldet sich dann also ein
guckte mir mit dem heute-journal update
und wir empfehlen ihnen doch sehr 37
grad gleich nach und auf jeden fall
ehemalige insassen des ddr zuchthauses
cottbus haben ihren früheren knast
gekauft und ein menschenrechtszentrum
daraus gemacht sie packen an und wollen
warnen zu was diktaturen fähig sind es
lohnt sich schauen sie sich das an
gleich nach und widersinn
[Musik]
guten abend häufig ist es ja in
südeuropa viel sonniger als bei uns in
mitteleuropa nicht so aktuell ein großes
hoch hält die ganzen wolken von uns fern
und so scheint die sonne zwischen der
ostküste der adria und der côte d'azur
in südwest und in süd ost europa drehen
sich dagegen tiefs dort gibt es zum teil
unwetter und es bleibt doch recht kühl
die nachmittagstemperaturen hier am
östlichen mittelmeer lagen bei 5 bis 10
grad und in zentralspanien gab es heute
auch nur 10 grad bei uns war es dagegen
mit 20 grad am mildesten und das -hoch
peter held auch morgen auf jeden fall
noch durch es zieht allerdings weiter
nach westen und damit kommen wir hier in
norddeutschland auf die ostseite dieses
hochs heute nacht sinken die
temperaturen auf plus fünf bis minus
fünf grad und luftfrost also frost in
zwei meter höhe gibt es in diesen dunkel
türkisen bereich der himmel ist meist
klar und nur in der nähe von flüssen
oder seen kann sich vielleicht mal ein
bisschen dunst oder nebel bild der wind
ist schwach und kommt aus östlichen
richtungen morgen dreht er an der
ostseeküste aber schon auf nordost und
das hat konsequenzen für die temperatur
die liegen dort nämlich morgen nur bei
elf grad das wasser der ostsee ist
nämlich 5 grad kalt das wasser der
nordsee hat temperaturen von etwa sieben
grad dort liegen die werte bei 14 grad
in den nächsten tagen geht es ganz
ähnlich weiter auch mit dieser
waldbrandgefahr und es erwartet uns
weiterhin eine temperatur von 10 bis 20
grad guten abend